hey Greg hello thanks for coming back
here of course yeah I was going to be
for the folks who don't know who are you
what do you do now and what did you do
before
uh well I'm Greg Kasavin I work at a
studio called supergiant games were a
small independent studio just a few
blocks away from here in San Francisco
and we've made two games so far called
Bastion and transistor which thankfully
have done well enough for us to still be
in existence and fire two that I worked
here at GameSpot it was my first real
job and and I was editor-in-chief back
then but I started as an intern what
worked here for four ten ten years or so
and as part of that I got to review a
lot of really good games and
occasionally some not so good games as
well and one of the really really good
games was was World of Warcraft
massively multiplayer online
role-playing games have been around for
years now but it's taken this long for
the genres breakthrough hit to finally
emerge but World of Warcraft is indeed
that game this is just an incredible
accomplishment and an incredibly fun
game above all else it's filled with I
think a lot of the like most remarkable
qualities about that game were were
relatively subtle technical details
there were things like how it didn't
take like two minutes or whatever to
start playing the game you just like
double-click the icon
type in your password and you're in at
least after the first month once I got
the server stuff sorted so it was really
it was just fast and once you were in
the whole world was seamless and that
that blew me away
things like EverQuest they were all like
very kind of zone based so they were
just these big maps with big long
loading times in between the maps and
when the goal of an MMO is is to kind of
immerse you in the world at least that's
part of the goal the difference between
kind of a collection of maps with exit
points and load times and and this
impression of a big seamless world is
just a night and day difference it like
really delivered on just this kind of
fully realized seamless world and also
where the combat itself which was like
the core of the gameplay was was
actually just a fun fun to do both Solo
and and
and in groups so before you review this
you actually ended up doing an exclusive
or GameSpot yeah we GameSpot had the
world exclusive like first preview of
World of Warcraft this was years before
it came out as is has sometimes been the
case for Blizzard games so we spent the
day with them seeing seeing what they
had there they showed the kind of
seamless environment they showed the art
style and the character design and
everything and they you know again at
that point we I was talking a lot with
them about like EverQuest and stuff like
that what they were taking from it was
there any sense back then this was going
to be a game that was going to have the
longevity I think that that was totally
unimaginable like the level of success
had achieved they could not have
possibly anticipated I think for sure
though the the game immediately came
across as like the most ambitious thing
that Blizzard had thus far set out to do
I think I think they were very much
ambitious with it while at the same time
having that kind of patented Blizzard
pragmatism and when you reviewed it was
there any could you ever have thought
that it was going to last the festival
you know I wonder Warcraft is in in my
10 years of reviewing games at GameSpot
it's one of the it's one of the highest
ratings I ever gave out I for sure had a
sense that this is a revelatory game in
its in a genre this is a big deal um to
what what that meant exactly you know
surely I didn't anticipate like being
here talking about it ten years later
but yeah I mean that level of success a
you know peaked at what like twelve
million or more EverQuest was only which
was seen as a huge hit with something
like 400,000 subscribers as a massive
hit that was like what the success
criteria was you know Blizzard had
launched big online games before and had
gone through some of those woes before
like with Diablo 2 and stuff so they
knew going in that there was going to be
a lot of demand and they you know and
they thought they had like I think it
was something like they thought they had
like three times as much sort of
capacity as they needed and then it was
it was just nowhere near enough so they
they had to scramble for a while but
obviously you know people were ended up
being forgiving of that initial rough
patch